all right fellas first 6 minutes everyone
first shift ready all right right off the
Hop we're bumping guys we're jumping off face
offs alie's got the rest here let's rock and
roll starting line up for C Nets chicky jbd
we got Brady Norris and [Applause] Vladimir a
beautiful fall afternoon in Stockholm Sweden
it's the global series The buildup is done
the waiting is over Minnesota wild take
on the Ottawa Senators Come on B D let's
go Bo come on J SP let's go please welcome
back to Sweden Ottawa Senators Legend Daniel
alfredson and now Daniel alfredson will
walk straight from the ceremonial face
off right to the Ottawa bench all good all
I say we got this baby it's time to drop
the puck and here we go from Stockholm
here's a chance for kachuck in save by
gust out out out out guys simple
plays here I like your skir man keep
going keep going here boys let's keep
boys he's ping me come on boys
sta fires save Guston get closer
down the Zone hey we got to make some plays down
there time expires here in the opening
period Ottawa Minnesota scoreless through
one underway in the second period
sharp on our changes here boys
[Applause]
communicate walk through the slot fired one that
came off the end glast and Branson with his glove
cover the puck that's going to be a penalty shot
Minnesota has been awarded a penalty shot for an
Ottawa player closing his hand on the park in
the crease Johansson in all alone Johanson on
the forehand backhand save is made by forsberg
so the swed stops the swed and remains scoreless
keep getting it in boys keep getting it in
getting after it here Ross's up with the slot
that's picked up by zarell comes to the point
favor a shot they score it may have been tipped
in front by Rossi and the Wild At The Game's
first tally here in Stockholm it's one nothing
Minnesota Minnesota Wild have a
lead after two periods middle middle
[Applause] middle good hit smack
that every time GL you got first
guy we're going to get one here here's a
breakaway chance busting in BR the shot
scores Brom a breakaway blast pass
from the goalie sub sweed to sweep
to the back of the net and the pride of e
sweep T the game in one come on boys not a
board Minnesota penalty number 20 2 minutes
for slashing it was under way under his glove
you reach in GB it pass C's power play 212% of
the year to chuck with a shot save by Guston
and these teams will put a point in the bank
and go to overtime stay behind I'm going to go
for right up right up yeah boys almost fans here
in Stockholm seen a little bit of everything and
now they're going to see a shoot up shoots
makes the A and he's stopped by forsburg go
Bo shooting number n Josh Norris Here Comes
Norris for Ottawa Norris [Applause] scores
Eric s must score to keep the wild alive
a forsberg save wins it for the Senators
swed against swed moves in goes back and tries
to forb nothing work and Ottawa wins it in the
shootout and the Senators win both games in
[Applause] Stockholm that's it fellas I let
you guys have the room hell of a job tonight by
a lot of guys obviously the sweets brought her
to the table Brandy great call he outstanding
uh Brandy great call but I got to give it to
my bar we came here for know the four points
and and know ended up uh working out for us
but uh it's a lot of great memories you know
forsburg branom you know got to come back end
up playing an awesome game tonight to help
us win great game boys uh let's go party now